a film critic in London wrote which
critic doesn't matter that Hollywood has
no more new stars he's crazy
evidence the presenters of the next
award the lady whom the same critic
called superb in Bob and Carol and Ted
and Alice and the gentleman whom he
called powerful in deliverance Dyan
Cannon and Burt Reynolds
mmm-hmm thank you you look powerful
we're going to give the scoring Awards I
know Moses got a flat tire we're all
fallible I mean you can be here to
present the award and not have to carry
a tune yeah I never even thought of that
well enough the nominations for the Best
Original dramatic score are John
Williams images Charles Chaplin Raymond
rash and Larry Russell limelight Buddy
Baker Napoleon and Samantha John
Williams again the Poseidon Adventure
and John Addison sleuth and the winner
is you better open it when my luck is
running will be empty
the winners are Charles Chaplin Raymond
rash and Larry Russell for long life
accepting the award for limelight
Candice Bergen
morning
I think I should explain that limelight
was made 20 years ago but has not been
released in this country until this year
and from one of the warmest most
wonderful men I have met thank you very
much from Charlie Chaplin and my
brothers George Gary and Gordon Russell
I want to thank the Academy very much on
behalf of my my dad I'd like to thank
the Academy
is he always wanted to write something
that would be remembered after he was
gone and Andy did it thank you very much
now the nominees for best scoring and
adaptation our cabaret adapted by Ralph
burns Lady Sings the Blues adapted by
Gill ash key Man of La Mancha adapted by
Laurence Rosenthal and the winner is the
winner is Ralph burns for cabaret
thank you how can you go wrong when you
work with artists like Liza and Joe and
Bob Fosse calling the shots and I just
want to thank sites your and Marty Baum
and all you Academy members I love you
all thank you